- [Narrator] We're told that
the double number line shows
that five pounds of avocados cost $9.
And so what is going on here
with this double number line?
This shows how as we increase
the number of avocados,
how the cost increases.
So for example, when we have
zero pounds of avocados,
it costs us $0.
When we have five pounds of avocados,
it costs us $9.
And so, if you look at
any point over here,
let's say you look right over here.
This would be, let's
see, this is one, right?
This is one, two, three, four, five.
If you look at one, this
point on the cost number line
would tell you how much one
pound of avocado would cost.
Two pounds of avocados,
how much would that cost?
You would look at this second
number line right over there.
So they ask us, based on the ratio shown
in the double number
line, what is the cost
for one pound of avocados?
So pause the video and think about it.
Remember, one pound of avocados
on this top number line,
we look at this second number line,
the cost would be right over here.
What is this going to be?
Well, we could just set it up as a ratio.
The ratio of pounds of avocados to cost
is going to be, let me
do this in some colors.
So if I have five pounds of avocados,
it is going to cost me $9.
So the ratio of pounds to
dollars is five to nine.
So if I were to have one pound of avocado,
one pound of avocado,
I have divided by five to
get one pound of avocado.
I would have to do the
same thing for the cost.
So if I divide nine by five,
this is going to be nine fifths dollars.
Nine fifths dollars would
be the cost of one pound.
Well, nine fifths isn't
always the most natural way
to write money, so you
can view this nine fifths
is equal to one and four fifths,
which is equal to one and eight 10ths,
which is equal to 1.8,
or you could say this is $1.80.
So if you were to go onto
this double number line,
the cost of one pound of avocado,
this point right over here would be $1.80.
If you said two pounds of avocados,
well, now you would double it.
So this would be $3.60,
and you would go on and on and on
all the way until you got to $9 here.
Let's do another example.
So here, we are told the
double number line shows
how many model trains
Irene can build in a week.
So we can see, in zero weeks
she can't build any trains,
but in one week she can build nine trains.
And they asked us, which
table represents the rate
of Irene building model trains?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
So once again, every week
she can build nine trains.
So one way to think about it is
the ratio of week to trains
would be one
to nine.
So let's see.
If I look at this table, I
just wanna see where the ratio
between weeks to trains
stays at one to nine.
So five to 45, that is still one to nine.
To go from one to five,
I've multiplied by five.
And then to go to nine to 45,
I've also multiplied by five.
So this one checks out.
And another way to think about
it, is 45 is nine times five.
So nine times.
That might be an easier
way to think about it.
Over here, 12 to 108, that's, once again,
12 times nine is 108.
And then 26 to 234.
Let's see, 26 times 10
would be 260, minus 26.
Yeah, it would be 234.
So this is nine times.
So in all of these cases,
the ratio of trains
or the ratio of weeks to
trains is one to nine.
So this one is looking good,
so I'll just circle that in.
But let's just make sure
that this one doesn't work.
Over here, the ratio of weeks
to trains is nine to one,
not one to nine.
The train should be nine times the weeks,
while here the weeks is
nine times the train.
So just looking at that first one,
we know that this is
not going to work out.
Let's do one last example.
The double number line shows
how many snowballs Jacob
and his friends can make in one minute.
No minutes, they can make zero snowballs.
In one minute, they can make 12.
Complete the table to
show the same information
as the double number line.
So once again, pause this video
and see if you can work this out.
Well, we can think about it as a ratio.
The ratio of minutes
to snowballs is one to 12.
So minutes to snowballs is one to 12.
Or another way to think about it is,
the snowballs is going to
be 12 times the minutes.
And so over here, if I have 12 snowballs,
we already know that's
going to be one minute.
If I have 48 snowballs,
let's just think about it.
To go from 12 to 48 you
have to multiply by four.
So you have four times as many snowballs,
it's gonna take you four
times as many minutes.
And then if you go to five,
to go from one to five
you multiply by five, so
you're gonna have five times
as many snowballs as you
would be able to make
in one minute.
So five times 12 is 60, and we're done.
It could be one to 12,
four to 48, five to 60.
For every five minutes,
you can make 60 snowballs,
or they make 60 snowballs.